[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous comprenez que j'ai très
difficile de commencer
d'abord il ya des orateurs il ya eu des
films de tedx et puis on vous dit allez
il faut y aller et en plus on a une
superbe salle et je voudrais vous
applaudir alors bien sûr merci d'être là
samedi après midi alors qu'il fait bon
et puis merci surtout à toutes les
toutes les les toutes les équipes
organisatrices de ce de ce grand
événement alors on oublie parle de moi
et moi ça m'intéresse pas trop ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que je voudrais
me parler de d'où vient parce qu'il faut
jamais oublier d'où on vient alors non
mais pas mes parents à mes grands
parents mes arrière grands parents sont
arrivés en afrique dans les années entre
1897 et 1900 en fait le compte
je ne sais plus je suis un héros
c'est ça mon problème à l'époque on
faisait partir les gens de où on partait
c'est dire donc le liban parce que j'ai
quand même une origine que je peux pas
oublier
on était dans les bat on disait on nous
amène aux états unis aux amériques de
pas hésiter à en parler pas on dira aux
amériques et les gens partaient dans les
bateaux et débarque à marseille de
marseille les amener à dakar s'était pas
tout à fait la même chose
une fois qu'il est à dakar c'était
tellement chaleureux c'était tellement
beau on y rester mais mon grand père et
mon arrière grand père paternel lui
s'est trompé de bateau à marseille et il
est parti en argentine et mon arrière
grand père maternel a remarqué que son
ami n'était pas là donc il a récurent
libara y aille plus hype alternait sa
femme l1 pendant ce temps là et le temps
que la lettre revienne en arrière grand
père avait une femme et famille une
forme une famille donc je dois avoir des
pontons des neveux des cousins peut-être
des petits cousins en argentine en tout
cas il a quitté l'argentine
il est revenu sur le bateau sur le
bateau il a rencontré l'espagnol et il a
fait mon grand père
nouvelle sachez milan j moi j'arrive en
côte d'ivoire en 1959 et en 1959 on est
allé à treichville
mais le treichville d'avant l'avenue 21
avec tous les corps entiers l'avenue 16
écoles comme entier et est pas là cités
arras y'avait pas levé jeu il y avait
deux allées avec une allée centrale
c'était superbe il n'y avait même pas
encore je pense qu'il est bon sur nos
mémoires le la presqu'île qui relie
aujourd'hui
billetterie à apport bruit tout ça pour
vous dire que je ne sais pas si je suis
un ouf parce que j'ai vu construire mon
pays et mon pays c'est celui-là alors ce
théâtre à saint jean bosco
mais jamais un mec qui s'appelle et
dieudonné et puis bon on était une
famille très modeste et quand je lis
entre en 6e j'avais 10 ans mes parents
m'ont dit mais qu'est ce qu'on fait et
je voulais les hauts plateaux le plateau
pour nous que c'était avoir un rang
social au dessus
c'était là où il y avait tous les
toubabs ou
parce qu'elles savent j'embaucherai à
l'époque on était trois blancs
et j'ai la saint-jean beaucoup et du
plateau en 6e 4 et mes parents qui
avaient pas les moyens
je suis né à l'ol le 23 décembre
exactement mais il fait un super
l'anniversaire et j'avais invité tous
mes amis de l'école enfin dans l'école
de la classe ont été 35 les toubabs où
les allemands les les ivoiriens qui
étaient là j'ai attendu de 17h à 23h
personne n'est venu
alors mes parents et j'ai été très sympa
m'ont vu dans un coin m'ont dit mes
tickets c'est pas grave on en est là
avec toi
les personnes pouvaient ressentir ce que
j'avais ressenti moi ce moment là à ce
moment là j'étais l'étranger je
comprenais pas j'étais l'étranger
pourquoi il n'était pas venu
et puis j'essaie de comprendre et c'est
peut-être à ce moment là que j'ai
découvert ce que je veux devenir plus
tard ce que je devenais plus tard sept
membres du monde ne pas d'un étranger ce
que je voulais faire plus tard
ce n'est pas être indifférents ce qui
s'est passé parce que ça faisait trop
mal
cd comprend pourquoi il n'était pas venu
pour quoi j'avais cette différence
achetez libanaises étaient européens
bloqués j'étais musulman il était
chrétien ou juif je sais pas ou
orthodoxes
gt et gt noir donc j'étais café au lait
pour les lois c'est ce qu'on disait des
libanais à l'époque on disait les
syriens et puis pour les européens
j'étais pas assez blanc finalement donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait
bien que deux choix ou non différence ou
la différence pour l'indifférence par
rapport à toutes ces différences hasselt
et que tout le monde soit différent et
que tout le monde vienne dans ce monde
c'était pas mal problème c'était eux le
problème
ils avaient peur de l'étranger alors il
fallait jusque dans ma tête je puisse
retrouver une façon de fonctionner
différentes
j'étais peut-être très jeune mais j'ai
compris qu'à ce moment là il fallait
aller vers les autres
il fallait montrer aux autres rabat les
mêmes oreilles le même lait mais
monsieur le même corps etc en partie ce
moment là ensemble égal avec ses
différents cela on pouvait vivre
ensemble on pourrait coller ensemble
donc à partir de ce moment là il a fallu
construire un parcours un destin
et
je continue mes études j'ai fait mes
études de médecine et on vient de le
dire
et puis c'était pas assez s'est passé
parce que toute ma vie a été régie sur
quatre principes celui qui ne sait pas
qui ne s'est pas tu ne sais pas c'est un
ignorant
on laisse tomber ça sert à rien de
discuter avec quelqu'un qui pense qu'il
a toujours raison
ça les théories ces intégristes les gens
qui sont comme autant de bornes et vous
perdez votre temps vous perdre de
l'énergie
ensuite le deuxième principe c'était il
fallait pas s'encombrer avec les
agitateurs du temps il ya des gens qui
s'agitent outre on peut le temps qu'ils
prennent des selphy ils font ça ils ont
internet ils vont prendre un hamburger
le film ils vont nous assure facebook
cessera ordinaires dont jeanne hamburger
waouh ça apporte beaucoup de choses non
on a même le goût de hamburgers mdr
merci de rappeler nos morts de rire
non tout ça va c'est difficile par
contre parmi ces personnes quand vous
rencontrez il ya des gens qu'il faut
aider il ya des gens qui ont envie
d'avancer
il ya des gens qui veulent partir plus
loin sans vous avec vous notre cas il
faut donner le petit coup de pouce le
petit coup de pouce extrêmement
important est la chose la plus
importante ce sont les études - dès que
je commençais à avoir mon premier
salaire j'ai mis en place une bourse
personnel pour aider les enfants ou les
jeunes d'aller à l'école ça commençait
déjà avec les enfants de myst de les
employés de la maison il fallait
absolument que les enfants aillent à
l'école et à ce jour j'ai à mon actif
personnelle de ma bourse personnel
autour des 10 personnes qui sont à
l'école qui font des études qui sont aux
états unis qui sont au canada qui sont à
londres et qui sont en france et qui
sont à abidjan
toutes les années
dans mes cordes quel que soit mon
activité s'est pris en compte
il est hors de question de ne pas aider
quelqu'un dans le code et c'en est tous
capables de le faire c'est pas une
question de moyens c'est une question de
volonté
on est tous capables de 5000 francs à
quelqu un poil à l'école après les apu
coûte cher mais vous savez c'est
lorsqu'on entreprend quelque chose que
les choses se mettent en place
aujourd'hui je sais que mon acte mon
initiative j'en ai parlé à des personnes
autour de moi et là on est en train de
mettre une bourse en place pour amener
un artiste un bon artiste à londres
parce que ce qu'il fait ne le fait on ne
fait pas ici et donc on a le temps de
mettre une bourse en place donc voyez
ces deux accusés que l'on peut faire
tout seul ne pas s'encombrer des gens
qui perdent leur temps la troisième
chose était même très importante ce que
le pare brise
il est quand même plus grand que le
retrouver heures si on sent qu'on de
tout ce qui nous empêche de tout ce qui
nous enchaînent de tous il bloque non
n'avance pas
le pare brise si le futur c'est ce qu'on
voit c'est ce que vous entreprenez c'est
vos projets c'est comment je vais aller
de l'avant n'est pas en fermant les yeux
dans les ouvrants et en accueillant tous
les projets tous les gens qui veulent
avancer vous les accompagnez de notre
monde parce qu'on est tous capables
d'avancer ensemble
ça c'est très important donc il faut
pour cela n'est rien laisser au hasard
avoir une analyse objective de chaque
chose alors il faut pas rêver
le rêve c'est bien concrétiser c'est
mieux non
c'est ça n'allait pas rêvé d'être
astronaute pourquoi pas mais à un moment
donné il faut que je mette en évidence
ensuite il faut pouvoir être à la base
de chaque acteur parce que si à un
moment donné il ya un problème
vous avez le plan b il faut que le plan
b soit en vous à chaque moment à chaque
instant parce que vous faites bloquer la
pub bloqué pour la technique qu'est ce
qu'on fait on se tait non il faut
continuer donc si une analyse objective
de ce que vous faites de ce que vous
devez faire c'est très important est la
4ème choses aussi très importante c'est
l'amour il faut aimer ce qu'on fait il
faut aimer ce qu'on fait il faut que
d'émotions parce qu'ensemble on peut
dire yes we can et ça c'est très
important par rapport au monde
aujourd'hui ensemble nous pouvons
réussir c'est ensemble que nous
réussissons c'est toujours une équipe
qui gagne c'est jamais une personne
ceux qui pensent qu'ils sont seuls dans
le monde et se trompe mais au ton
croyais allemand
alors j'ai 61 ans contrairement à ce
qu'a dit le monsieur j'ai pas vraiment
de médecine je continue à exercer ma
médecine
j'ai toujours médecin médecin jour
médecin toujours chaud comme les scouts
et dans les gens me disent ah mais voilà
il a laissé tomber la médecine pour
faire la culture ou les arts
je dis non j'ai pas laisser la médecine
j'ai laissé le mercantilisme d'un
médecine par rapport à la médecine vrai
que j'exerce parce que les gens ils ont
le droit d'être soigné
je t'envie de tomber sous la guillotine
des assurances de celui qui n'a pas les
moyens c'est pas pour ça je fais la
médecine
c'est fait la médecine pour soigner les
gens et je suis contenir soigner les
gens j'ose dire gratuitement et c'est
extrêmement beau de le faire et je le
fais parce que je fais les arts alors me
dit après mais qu'est ce qu'ils font
poindre un médecin
jeudi il faut un bon metteur en scène
parce que le bon metteur en scène permet
aux uns et aux autres de pouvoir être à
l'aise et de l'idée le malade pour
justement pour voir à un moment donné
qu'il se puisse se dénuder complètement
et qu'on puisse discuter ensemble
merci de m'avoir écouté et bonne
continuation
[Applaudissements]